[Musica]
è per me un piacere essere qua e potervi
raccontare la mia storia
diciamo che nella vita
molte volte mi sono trovate nella
condizione di dover premere il tasto
reset
a cominciare da capo questa è una cosa
che capita a tanti a tutti in
particolare nel 2013
mio marito ed io abbiamo deciso di
lasciare una situazione lavorativa
incerta qua in italia è di di andare
verso il freddo canada abbandonando così
la nostra la nostra bella sardegna
qui abbiamo abbiamo trovato un lavoro io
ho trovato il lavoro dei miei sogni ma
diciamo un visto non rinnovato ci ha
fatto rientrare in italia nel marzo 2014
quindi abbiamo detto va bene
e successo di nuovo ricominciamo non c'è
nessun problema allora è successo che
due mesi dopo a maggio ho ricevuto
un'email dall'università di cagliari
una di quelle email che di solito
cestino perché devo dire che la vita
universitaria mi ha sempre annoiato un
po poi i miei colleghi lettera non tutti
molto molto noiosi diciamo però questa
mi ha incuriosito parecchio
si parlava di fare impresa però non era
molto chiaro effettivamente che cosa
volesse dire si parlava di un di un
percorso non ho capito detto va bene
comunque mando la mia candidatura tanto
si trattava soltanto di mandare il mio
nome
questo mi ha portato a fare un test di
un test attitudinale e poi ad entrare in
ad essere ammessa in questo percorso
questo percorso ricordo benissimo il
primo giorno si parlava di incubatori e
acceleratori start up idc ma che roba è
era molto diverso dai miei studi
sicuramente poi per aiutarci ben bene
confonderci ancora di più le idee ci
siamo ritrovati in un campo da rugby mi
sono ritrovata lincoln 120 sconosciuti e
ancora continuavano capire e gli altri
si facevano la stessa da umana ma che
c'entra questo con col fare
l'imprenditore e l'imprenditore non è
quello vestito di tutto punto che che si
occupa di affari importanti
beh questa è la diciamo un originale
fase di team building infatti è stato
proprio lì che fra tutti quegli
sconosciuti ho incontrato giorgiantonio
che potete vedere nelle foto che sono
sono diventati poi i miei soci
giorgia era fresca di laurea in economia
manageriale e antonio laureando in
informatica insieme ci siamo trovati
bene ci siamo uniti in team e abbiamo
deciso di intraprendere questo percorso
questo percorso che si chiama
contamination lab
cosa fa mette insieme studenti di varie
facoltà favorendo appunto la
contaminazione di cui tanto si è di cui
tanto si è parlato al fine di diffondere
la cultura d'impresa e arrivare alla
creazione di start up innovative da
tutto questo è nato cosa è nato in 3d mi
quello che facciamo in the di mi è un
gioco di parole tra il sardo che
l'inglese è in sardo significa ascoltami
ora è stato svelato
ascoltami perché perché ci occupiamo
appunto di sordità abbiamo deciso di
concentrarci su un problema reale è il
motivo vi è stato anticipato il motivo
sono i miei genitori sono entrambi sordi
quindi io sono sono cresciuta proprio
con la consapevolezza di tutto ciò che è
l'assurdità che la sordità comprende
quindi le difficoltà i pregiudizi
ho avuto un'infanzia molto molto felice
diciamo che sono diventata responsabile
molto in fretta
sono stata spesso per loro
le orecchie ma anche un interprete già a
due anni facevo le chiamate dal medico
però devo dire che ho imparato anche a
parlare molto presto anche se magari mia
madre quando mi portava in giro per per
il paese col passeggino le persone
afferma voli dicevano ma che carina
questa bambina ma parla allora io
iniziamo a parlare
e allora capivano che effettivamente la
sordità non non mi aveva toccato e che
comunque io avevo ampie capacità di
parole quindi questa qui potete vedere
una mia foto da piccola appunto era una
bambina una bambina bella energica che
ha sempre combattute pregiudizi perché
ovviamente i bambini non capivano quindi
magari mi prendevano in giro
mia nonna ovviamente le rincorreva con
la scopa e io cercavo comunque di di far
capire loro che dove loro vedevano
qualcosa di diverso qualcosa di strano
io vedevo una grandissima ricchezza e ho
cercato sempre di farlo anche col
sorriso perché magari mi dicevano ma
perché tuo padre parla in modo così
strano dice voi americano poi quel
successo che la mia esperienza personale
ha dato diciamo ha dato il via al mio
lavoro ovviamente ho avuto la fortuna
appunto di incontrare i miei soci che si
sono appassionati è che sono partite da
una situazione in cui di sordità non
sapevano nulla e adesso ci sono dentro
con tutte le scarpe durante il nostro
viaggio sia unito in corsa anche
quell'altro bambino che vedete lì
lui si chiama leonardo ed è un ingegnere
elettronico e anche lui ha portato la
sua esperienza leonardo è sordo fin
dalla nascita quindi insieme siamo
abbiamo creato un team molto più forte
ancora più competente abbiamo cercato di
trovare una soluzione che permettesse
alle persone sorde di sentirsi
e appunto più indipendenti più libera al
sicuro dentro l'ambiente domestico è
rilevare rilevare i suoni che ne fanno
parte ed essere avvisati immediatamente
[Musica]
parliamo di suoni come quelli che noi
udenti diamo per scontato come il
campanello qualcuno che bussa alla porta
o il timer degli elettrodomestici o dei
suoni importanti come può essere
l'allarme quindi questo sistema è
costituito scusate è costituito da dei
sensori universale di vibrazioni sonore
che si applicano direttamente sulla
fonte sono una scelta che possono poi
essere spostati a seconda delle
preferenze c'è una fase di registrazione
con una applicazione non appena questo
non si verifica la persona in tempo
reale riceve una notifica al proprio
paul's uno smartwatch che abbiamo creato
questo smartwatch fibre si illumina è e
indica la fonte sono una rilevata in più
per mettiamo anche alle persone di
chiamarsi da una stanza all'altra di
chiedere aiuto in caso di emergenza
perché succede che per esempio mio padre
sia in cucina è mia madre sia in camera
uno ha bisogno d'aiuto anche se urlano
tanto non li sente nessuno se non io che
vivo al piano di sotto
quindi l'abbiamo messo nello smart se
abbiamo risolto il problema
questo è un problema che chiede i numeri
importanti nel mondo
parliamo di 360 milioni di persone con
una disabilità uditiva grave in italia
parliamo di 7 milioni in questi numeri
sono incluse non soltanto le persone che
hanno un deficit profondo ma anche le
persone anziane che via via con l'età
perdono l'udito
questo volo spiegato cosa vogliamo fare
noi con in termini con in the navy
stiamo cercando di innanzitutto con la
soluzione tecnologica limitare i disagi
e potenziali pericoli che una persona
sorda si trova ad affrontare
ma tra i nostri obiettivi c'è anche
quello di diffondere un messaggio
positivo sulla sordità quindi far vedere
innanzitutto che non esiste
due mondi come come spesso viene inteso
quindi il mondo dei sordi nel mondo
degli utenti ma il mondo che ci piace
quello dove sordi udenti lavorano
insieme per per abbattere le barriere
per far capire la grande opportunità e
il grande valore di lavorare insieme
in conclusione cosa gli posso dire che
io mi sono ritrovata da un giorno
all'altro da tradurre greco a stringere
la mano a mattarella perché perché
perché ci ho creduto perché non ho mai
perso la la determinazione e quindi
l'importante per quanto per quanto mi
riguarda insomma penso che sia per tutti
così è provarci poi male che vada
insomma si ricomincia da capo perché
tanto questo è anche il il bello della
vita e poi la vita appunto chissà quali
altre sorprese ci riserva quindi non
abbiate paura di ballo tolare quel
foglio su cui stava descrivendo e
prenderne uno bianco perché magari
proprio in quel foglio bianco che state
prendendo potrete scrivere il capitolo
più bello della vostra vita
grazie
[Musica]